leicht anfühlen nur den Ballon wirklich
nur leicht Masse der mit dem Jacket
unter wasserplattform Zusammenbau von
der unterwasserblattform schieberwechsel
Zeichen wie ausgemacht viermal dann
holen wir den Schieber und das Gestell
rein hier dort mit leicht angefühlten
wie gesagt alles klar
das Jagdkommando operiert zu Lande zu
Wasser in der Luft
im Wasser haben wir die Kampftaucher und
die pioniertaucher beim Jagdkommando auf
der einen Seite die Kampftaucher die
klassische gefechtsaufgaben erfüllen die
sich zum Beispiel unter Wasser unerkannt
Annähern an einen aufklärungsobjekt das
kann jetzt ein Ufer sein in einem
größeren sehen in Österreich oder auch
im Ausland in küstenwalen Bereichen oder
auch bei Donaubrücken um Informationen
für nachfolgende Kräfte zu liefern und
auf der anderen Seite eben die
pionierter die vor allem unter Wasser
Arbeiten machen die dort
Arbeitsplattformen errichten die Berge
und rette rettungsstätigkeiten machen
Assistenzeinsatz hier oben auf der Suche
trainieren wir unter Wasser Arbeiten
unter Wasser tauchen und der besonders
schweren Bedingungen einerseits die
Kälte
andererseits die Höhe und natürlich die
geschlossene Eisdecke die so ein
Aussteigen aus dem Wasser natürlich nur
erschwert ermöglicht und wenn man das
Eisloch nicht findet dann braucht man
eben relativ rasch eine gut
funktionierende Zusammenarbeit mit den
Rettungskräften dass man einen verloren
gegangen einen Taucher sicher werden
kann
erstens wird Sicherheitstraining
durchgeführt das heißt Gewöhnung an die
Ausrüstung unter Eis und auch die
Kontrolle das sämtliches Material auch
ändern und funktioniert der zweite
Ausbildungsschritt ist dann
Selbstrettung und Kameradenrettung dass
im Falle eines Unfalls die Rettungskette
auch aus dem Wasser an Land gut
funktioniert dazu haben wir auch einen
Arzt vor Ort und der dritte
Ausbildungsschritt dieser Fortbildung
sind leichte unter Wasser arbeiten um
eben
Suchaufgaben und Bergungen durchführen
zu können
[Applaus]
wir haben ausländische Gäste als
Minentaucher als Eckernförde wir haben
aus dem taucherausbildungszentrum Percha
am Starnberger See und wir arbeiten auch
mit der Wasserrettung aus Kärnten
zusammen und führen hier Übungen durch
die Herausforderungen beim Tauchen sind
wir auch im Hintergrund sieht
tauchen unter Eis erstens einmal die
winterlichen Bedingungen an der
Oberfläche wir haben hier teilweise
Minusgrade das heißt die Ausrüstung muss
dazu geeignet sein sehr warme
Unterzieher trocken doch Anzug
Wärmesysteme und auch dementsprechend
wenn es möglich ist Kreislaufsysteme um
warme Gase unter Eis zu haben die
Wassertemperaturen liegen zwischen 0 und
4°c das heißt die Durchhaltefähigkeit
der Taucher je nach System liegt
zwischen 45 Minuten und sage ich mal in
etwa 2 Stunden oder etwas mehr die
Herausforderung
im Gegensatz zum Sommer sind die
Witterungsbedingungen und wenn man hier
auf der Tura auch noch
betrachtet die Höhenlage das heißt es
kommen andere die kompressionsmodelle
und auch andere doch Modelle
zum Zug
in dieser Fortbildung wir werden
Knotenkunde und äh leichte handwerkliche
Tätigkeiten durchgeführt um zum Beispiel
im Fall eines Einbruches eines
Fahrzeuges unter Eis dieses
befestigen zu können und für eine
Bergung vorbereiten zu können das
Zielpublikum für diese aus und
Fortbildung sind Arbeiter
österreichischen Bundesheer die
Ausbildung ist relativ langwierig das
heißt der Taucher beginnt das erste in
einem Pionierbataillon als Unteroffizier
seinen Dienst wenn er die
unteroffiziersausbildung fertig oder
vollendet hat beginnt er dann mit der
Tauchausbildung mit einer
Grundausbildung die im Moment ca 11
Wochen dauert
um eben leichte und schwere unter Wasser
Arbeiten durchführen zu können benötigt
der noch einmal ca 8 bis 9 Wochen Penny
doch Ausbildung und die Dauer des einer
eishock-ausbildung dauert in
österreichischen Bundesheer ca 2 Wochen